yeah talking points don't work again and
unfortunately the left is you know their
whole deal is closing ranks they hand
down their ideas like doctrine whereas i
think the right is still kind of open
source to it to a degree because the
right goes by principles more so than
doctrine that's a good point
whatever the the there's two factions
and it's a centralized and decentralized
that's that's really basically what it
is i mean that's how the populists took
over and that's why you know the
democrats you know they're beating back
the leftists with sticks yes they
capitulate every now and again because
it's just trendy and you've got these
kids that don't know any better and they
want to get them on board but at the
same time
you know
the right won their revolt and took over
the republican party largely even if
it's just for show even if a lot of
politicians you know you just you get a
lot of these old these old guard
republicans that are now adopting the
whole populist message but even if it's
just for sure trick primarium get them
out yeah you want you want me to vote
republican
okay primary all these guys yes yeah all
of them
get them out and i'm pretty sure
everyone on the trial the trump
supporters agree yes right now's out i i
do think it's fair to i think it's
unfair to call them rhinos though
republican in name only because i'm like
the truth be told the republican the
republican party and the majority are do
nothings yeah you know it's like the one
or two guys like rand paul maybe who's
going to do something different so he's
the he's the one who's only republican
name he's more libertarian and
principled at the beginning of the show
i was thinking i feel like american
politics has is is different now like
it's still the same suit american
politics but whoever's wearing it is
like because we're in the age of social
media and popularity contests now i
don't think that term that these endless
terms work anymore it's too it's too
easy to get super popular and then have
like totalitarian control basically so
we've really got to kind of
you know reboot or reevaluate or
transition there's probably better words
i get what you're saying and i mean it's
happening to an extent the democrats
they run their party in a very 90s to
2000s era kind of way that's why they
focus on big media corporation and all
that whereas the right has already
evolved so the left is still the left
and i when i say left i don't mean the
true left i mean this neoliberal
establishment they are still operating
in the clintonian era where you know you
go up you get a celebrity to say some
good things about you and then you know
you dance around for the camera and then
you go back to your dark room but
remember when hillary clinton was
campaigning and she put on a southern
drawl when she was in like alabama or
wherever she was like yo we have the
internet back in the day
back in the day the politician could go
to chicago and be like i'm just like you
guys i get a garage door opener just
like you and they could go to new york
and be like yo you vote for me and both
of these guys are getting out i'm going
to wipe these guys out and
it works people be like hey sounds like
me now when you do that they're like why
are you talking different aoc
actually did it remember when she like
she put on like a spanish
she put on a spanish accent yeah and
then people were like yo you don't sound
like that
and she's like i wasn't putting on an
accent that's just because i'm bilingual
and it's like dude
it it it worked when we were only
newspapers it would be like hillary
clinton came and said these words but if
you actually heard it she tries to
imitate the people there she did that in
her campaign it doesn't work these are
different times you can't do that stuff
but they still think it's 20 years ago
why well nancy pelosi is what she 80
something years old how old is she she
won i think dianne feinstein's 90 isn't
she yeah at some point you know these
politicians they reach their shelf life
and you know i think the gop a lot of a
lot of the old guard politicians gop are
really about to probably bow out just
because they they see with the writing
on the wall and that yeah it is good but
the issue is the right has a very big
talent scouting program think about this
or i mean a talent scouting
it or an issue with their talent
scouting program where
a lot of the people that you see come up
on the right you know they don't get a
lot of these people that are out on the
forefront on twitter making memes
spreading this information a lot of
these non-blue check but big-name
influencers they don't scout those
people they get the interns the people
that work for somebody that they know to
come up the yes men
and that's who they put in and these are
anti-charismatic people they don't quite
understand or relate and it's like
getting somebody like marjorie taylor
green you can say what you want about
her cue stuff and all of that
but she's different you know what i
can't stand
wear suits no i get it democrats in
congress are wearing suits but like
conservatives like mainstream
conservatives show up to events wearing
suits 19 year old kids wearing suits i'm
like you are not relatable to a regular
working class nobody wants that guy and
it's like you have all this talent right
here
but you keep on picking the same old
same old and then you're wondering why
you're getting stomped out by these
people that are using twitch streams and
they're sitting up here they're they're
reaching out to the kids and they're
inspiring youth to become leftists you
know i think a lot of people
conservative pop that are really
successful people that happen to be can
sort of go into business they don't go
into politics that's that's a big thing
too and you know that's that's honestly
the cycle that politics should follow is
that you should become very proficient
in something else in life
and then once you've done that once
you've accomplished all that you want
then go into politics that sounds pretty
similar to what trump did trump had
already made his money he had already
become a business magnate he had you
couldn't bribe him because he already
had everything so what do you want he
wanted the accolades of going into
politics and now when you have that
motivation
you're not out here trying to sell out
the highest bidder you're not out here
trying to wear a bunch of corporate
brands you're just trying to get your
legacy you know you're just trying to
get your legacy through and that's why i
didn't understand why they did not like
this guy like it's an insurance policy
trump gets in if he does bad his brands
suffer people remember trump as oh you
remember that guy that got in and he
just ruined everything kind of like what
we said about joe biden like trump would
not he wouldn't allow that to happen so
that's why i just didn't get that but
that's the cycle that politics is
supposed to follow but you missed trump
yet
i sure could go for some mean twits
right now all right
i would take 20 mean tweets yeah
barbecue prices yeah you know he's
looking good man yeah he looked at the
fast food
yeah something like that i remember 2019
man
best economy people were cheering jim
kramer was like best numbers of our
lives covet happened i can't blame trump
for covert i don't know you know but i
can't you know he was going along with
it he should have fired fiochi's a lot
of things he could have done better but
now you know it's a natural disaster of
sorts
but under under his administration in
the first few years i mean things were
skyrocketing yeah the economy was
through the roof booming business was a
booming now where are we i mean trump
didn't start any wars he was trying to
get our troops out of the middle east he
made some absolute foreign policy
mistakes often often with drone strikes
military strikes uh missile strikes
commando raids et cetera
but the past few past the last couple
years he was like he's pretty good i'm
like all right you know
donald trump's got a potty mouth but
this ain't bad and then when joe biden
comes along i'm like
i'll take the potty mouth plus trump's
second term agenda was legit like school
choice on there yeah now we're now we're
we're nine uh eight months in and it's
like democrats voted for this we got the
border crisis we got the afghanistan
withdrawal problem we've got an economic
crisis we've got the eviction crisis
we've got job shortages fuel shortages
food shortages holy
joe biden screwed off i won't blame him
the economy was was on its way down even
though they gave that one last ride
before they started printing the other
like we were already 18 trillion in
deficit but the rhetoric
but i mean at that point you know the
rhetoric around lockdowns definitely
accelerated it made it worse and you
know again there was nobody to take the
desantis approach and just say hey guys
let's just let's stop this follow me
trust me let's not lock down because
that's going to kill us where we're at
and
and there's a difference between the
debt and the economy the debt's a
problem it means you know we're going to
see inflation the government is
overspending it's over exerting itself
but when
you have debt the train is still moving
it's causing problems and it's bad but
when you just stop everything that was
the democrats now again donald trump
should have fired fouchy donald trump
was all about 15 days to slow the spread
but it was mostly democrat governors who
went hardcore trump does deserve some of
the blame for the cover response
absolutely could have fired fouch he
could have said no to a lot of the stuff
he thought he was doing something good
he was like i'm going to race a vaccine
out as fast as possible everyone yeah
well that was that was part of the issue
though that we took a vaccine-centered
approach again trump's original idea
with the red and green zones or however
they did it again just testing rapid
testing that was a much better approach
rapidly test the individuals you know
make sure number one the fact that we're
still using pcr is just you know it's in
the front because pcr doesn't detect
whether or not you're carrying a viral
load that you can actually transmit a
rapid test would be very much suited
towards that because that basically
gauges your load whether or not you can
actually give somebody covet or you
can't and then you quarantine the people
basically tell them hey go ahead and do
this stay away from these people and you
keep everything moving the fact is we
took a vaccine-centric
approach where we wanted to lock
everything down until we got vaccines
well we got them well hold on
we wanted to lock everything down for 15
days to slow the spread so hospitals
didn't overload within 15 days it turned
into just a couple more weeks then it
turned then it became just until we've
stopped coving
then it's like we'll get the vaccines
don't worry once that we have the
vaccines then we're back to normal then
we get the vaccines and they're like
okay well you've still got to wear your
mask to get the vaccine then they're at
the point where they're like look we
need everyone to do weekly tests and if
you don't want to do a weekly test get
the vaccine now we're at the point where
they're like even if you've gotten the
vaccine you need a weekly test that's at
university of arizona thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show come back to this channel
youtube.comcast irl monday through
friday at 8 pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you